so nice to finally meet you spider-man
hi everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery spider-man bar from
home review so I'll try to talk about as
much as possible without getting into
spoilers if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos we're still doing that
IMAX ticket giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a spider-man comment on the video the
movie itself was intended to be the
bookend for Marvel phase 3 even though
technically it's supposed to be the
first Marvel phase for film Kevin Feige
just reiterated that there was so much
stuff so much baggage that spider-man
himself in the MCU had to deal with that
this movie has the unenviable task of
following the biggest Marvel movie that
you've ever seen
Avengers endgame but a really helpful
comparison to make would be spider-man 2
from Tobey Maguire era and the amazing
spider-man 2 so even though as a
spider-man sequel and it's expected to
up the stakes in a big way it does
sidestep a lot of the classic land mines
that the franchise has had in the last
two iterations usually what that means
is is they do way too much way too fast
so with that in mind they did a really
good job of balancing the friendly
neighborhood spider-man the very
grounded way that they told far from
home like I'm just trying to deal with
small-time problems not really big
Avengers level stuff he just got back
from his big Avengers field trip
watching his hero die right in front of
him
there's no way that you're gonna top
stuff like that but they do manage to up
the spider-man stakes to a much more
worldwide big epic scale that you would
expect to without taking it too far
while still making him feel like he's a
friendly neighborhood spider-man but he
just has much much bigger problems to
deal with by the end of the film it's
really all about him dealing with the
idea of superhero identity who is he
going to become the trailers did a
pretty good job of spelling out the
stakes and yes there were a lot of
scenes from the trailers that did not
wind up in the movie so I'll address
that at the end of the video without
getting into really big spoilers but the
specter of Iron Man looms large in the
film who is going to be the next Iron
Man so the film trades heavily on Iron
Man's legacy
he's hugely important to the plot of the
film for a character who died before the
beginning of the story so some might
feel like he casts a shadow that's a
little too large and kind of overpowers
the Spider Man story at times but they
do a good job of showing you the PTSD
the Spider Man is trying to deal with
through Avengers infinity war avengers
endgame and just trying to figure out
what he's going to be doing next with
his life because even though he was a
sophomore during spider-man homecoming
in the snap happened five years have
gone by
they didn't age so they all have to go
to school in the next year it's not like
they're gonna skip a whole bunch of
years of school they do address all your
timeline questions for all these kids on
this big class field trip within the
first 5 10 minutes of the film it's a
pretty easy explainer but while you and
spider-man might still be completely
traumatized by the end of Avengers end
game and even though spider-man films in
general are about making spider-man
suffer as much as possible the film
doesn't get too depressing with it and
even though you've seen Tom hoenn crying
his eyes out through the trailers he
doesn't take it to Tobey Maguire levels
of bummed out spider-man this is a real
fine line you walk with stuff like that
and I think that Tom Holland has
benefited from just being around some of
these really high caliber actors like
Robert Downey jr. who's been kind of a
mentor and surrogate father figure to
him in real life ever since Captain
America Civil War you'll probably hear
some comparisons to some really big
seminal comic book moments from Tobey
Maguire spider-man 2 so even the
the actual story of the film is very
different they do trade on some similar
moments without completely retreading
everything so some things will feel very
familiar for a long time spider-man fans
whether you like that or you don't like
that that's part of the idea I think a
lot of comic book films because comic
books are a nostalgia medium show me the
things that I love but in a completely
fresh and different way so this film
does treat us a very familiar classic
spider-man moments some of you might be
frustrated with some of the things the
film does not do in rushing to set up a
billion other sequels it's pretty clear
from the story that Kevin Feige is a no
rush to take spider-man
to the nth degree it does take it to a
pretty epic scale but not in the way
that you would expect it given what they
did with previous spider-man franchises
so it does try to sidestep some of the
landmines of spider-man 3 from Tobey
Maguire era in amazing spider-man 2 from
Andrew Garfield era in that those films
just tried to open the door on
spider-man villains to just stuff as
many as possible in the films so couch
your expectations in terms of where the
franchise is going I know there been a
lot of rumors I'll mention that at the
end of the video there's always a lot of
rumors about where the franchise is
headed in the future and Sony's plans
for the next 10 years they do have
really big plans for the spider-man
character but Sony controls about 900
characters because they own the rights
to spider-man so even though spider-man
far from home is sort of the last film
before Marvel phase 4 it has to wrap all
of these things up it does do a good job
of being a very self-contained story so
won't completely ruin your enjoyment if
you haven't seen every other Marvel film
but if you are a longtime hardcore comic
book fan they do trade on a lot of very
classic Mysterio from his very first
appearance in the amazing spider-man
comics so as a character I never thought
that Mysterio would have worked in a
film like he just seems really silly
with the fishbowl helmet but they
totally made it work and I think a lot
of that credit goes to Jake Gyllenhaal
in his performance this
they're Mysterio clam
he's like Iron Man and Thor rolled in on
one famous story about how he almost
became spider-man during the Tobey
Maguire era when Toby got into a
standoff with a studio to renegotiate
for more money that was very brief
second it did end up happening obviously
we got Tobey Maguire and the film wound
up being one of the best comic book
films of all time and it still is as
cool as some of the things that they do
with the Mysterio character during the
film I just feel like it wouldn't have
completely worked had it not been Jake
Gyllenhaal so all credit goes to Kevin
Feige in the Marvel producers for
picking Jake Gyllenhaal obviously
there's like a stable of really
high-caliber actors of trying to get you
probably heard recently about how the
Eternals movie that they're getting
ready to shoot is trying to cast all
these really huge a list actors like
Keanu Reeves Angelina Jolie now Salma
Hayek the rest of the supporting cast
was great as part of the more friendly
neighborhood spider-man high school
storyline that they have running through
obviously you have the really big
Mysterio stuff that's happening that's
the big epic scale of the film then you
have all the friendly neighborhood
spider-man Peter just trying to be a
high school kid part of the story even
though the film takes a little while to
get going the supporting cast was great
Nick Fury it should go without saying
samuel l.jackson is fantastic there are
some really complicated things that are
going on with his character during the
film so be sure to pay attention to what
he's doing into what Mysterio is doing
it will definitely reward you when you
go see the film a second time just
because even though both the characters
have very different storylines they have
this really weird layered approach to
their characters in this film that are
different from previous films in the
case of samuel l.jackson we've never
seen Mysterio before but if you've ever
watched Jake Gyllenhaal and some of his
other more recent films he's known for
playing really complex characters so he
would not be wrong if you thought that
there was something weird about the way
some of his lines are delivered in the
trailers so yes there are a lot of
misleading things during the trailers
there was a really big montage that was
supposed to happen at the beginning of
the film that they just completely cut
out so there's a giant chunk of the
trailers that you won't see until the
blu-ray comes out they did say they
completely shot it they just cut out
minute they'll put it on the blu-ray as
part of the deleted scenes if you're not
a big spider-man or Tom Holland fan or
if you hated the franchise before this
this movie isn't gonna completely blow
you away but it is better than
spider-man homecoming in the franchise
is getting a lot closer to a really
solid third film we never really got the
chance with Andrew Garfield's amazing
spider-man franchise but because Sony
has been talking about live-action
spider-verse at some point in the next
10 years is always possible they could
address some of those hanging plot
threads from those different franchises
including Tobey Maguire's spider-man
franchise just depending on how things
go in the next five to seven years there
ever is and ever will great even though
I spend a lot of time following these
Marvel films there were a couple big
surprises for me in what they did with
the ending once you see it though you'll
have a much better idea for how they're
going to be pacing out the third film in
the franchise and potentially future
films after that I know there are a lot
of rumors about Sony planning for a
bunch of sequel trilogies including Tom
Holland they haven't revealed their
official plans for more spider-man films
after spider-man 3 but I do assume that
Tom Holland will resign his contract and
will continue to play the character for
at least the next several years but just
remember that I said that Kevin Feige
seems like he's in no rush to take
spider-man to the enth degree
sidestepping a lot of escalation
landmines from previous spider-man
franchises that'll make a little more
sense once you see the film and you see
what it is that they do at the end but
they do give you enough to go on with
the ending to give you an idea for where
spider-man 3 is gonna pick up and what
his problems are gonna be during that
film this is the second time that I've
seen the film so I will say spider-man
far from home definitely a top 3
spider-man film but I wouldn't say that
it's better than spider-man into the
spider-verse
or Tobey Maguire spider-man 2 which
still stands as my favorite spider-man
film of all time still one of my
favorite comic book films of all time
but it's still one of the best
spider-man films so far so it still
manages to be great despite some of the
minor issues that I have with it and the
idea that it has to follow avengers
endgame no film ever wants to follow
something like Avengers endgame but
somehow spider-man far from home manages
to pull it off
zendaya did a pretty good job with the
MJ character but your mileage will vary
on the teenage romance subplot they do
trade heavily on that because they're
trying to develop the classic MJ
spider-man romance but in a very
different way than you've seen it in
previous films there's a lot of really
technical questions you'll probably have
about specific things
spider-man making certain spider-man
gadgets that I'll address when we get to
my spoiler review
that'll post after the film comes out in
the United States next week I'll do a
post credit scene video there are two
post credits scenes there's a mid
credits in an actual post credits
they're very important so make sure you
stay after the credits longtime
spider-man fans will love them some of
you will just be really excited by them
but they are very very important for the
future of the franchise in the future of
the MCU so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see those
other spider-man videos post next week
I've got a Black Widow taskmaster video
that will probably post later today so
just look out for that but once you have
a chance to see the movie just leave
your non spoilery reactions in the
comments just because this video is
supposed to be a non-spoilery one I'll
name a giveaway winner when I post that
taskmaster video later today while you
wait for everything click here for that
last big spider-man far from home
trailer and click here to learn about
what Kevin Feige said about how
spider-man will crossover with venom in
future movies thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight